so one of the links that you will need
is this
first link server.tbio.info
and the second link is
learnomicslogic.com
so when you go to learn.omixlogic.com
uh you can create a profile and this is
a profile that is associated with this
program so i'll just explain
briefly what this means and and how to
use this
so let me go to the portal itself
so here you can register it's a free
registration
now once you are here you will notice
that right here
is your profile i can complete my
profile by clicking on this button right
here and i can add an image add some
social links
and i can add some explanation about my
background
so what's a useful uh type of
information that you can add here you
can add your degree
or university that you're a part of or
something like that that will be useful
uh then here you will see your level and
achievements
so what this is is uh an overview of
points
and achievements that you have been
working on
so this allows us to track your progress
and
essentially provide with a certificate
after you've completed the program here
you see your
level of subscription so if it says
basic that means
you have a free subscription if you have
a starter subscription that means
it is paid and you have access to the
premium coursework which
which is going to be included in this
program and here you have these
membership badges so these are the
different programs that you are part of
and once you have registered for the
program all the information that you
need
is going to be right here so all the
information about
upcoming sessions what you are doing and
what has been completed
you can see the associated courses the
meeting
with a mentor if you need one q a
and a certificate so all the information
is going to be right here
on your profile you'll be able to see
your progress
in the coursework that you are going
through the program
and you will get your certificate here
after you complete all the registration
on the program page there are several
important things to pay attention to
so the first one are the associated
asynchronous resources these are
projects and courses which means that
you can go in between our sessions and
learn some of the
more in-depth information about
different types of data sets that we're
going to be going through
or gaining some practical skills by
understanding
what are the methods and what are the
data sets that they are used to analyze
you will also see the link to
the session so the zoom link like
today's link you just can get it
from clicking on the zoom logo right
here
and you can also complete the session so
if you participate in the session
or if you have just watched a video of
the session which
will be also posted here you can click
on
complete session and that will be a step
in towards gaining your certificate
and finally we have a slack channel so
here's the program page
again i'm just going to paste the link
here this
is going to be visible only to those
that have
completed the registration so some of
you might not see this right now but
after today's session please go back to
this page to see
all of the details so as i mentioned
right here we have the zoom link this is
for today's zoom link
and here i can mark this session as
complete and it will be completed
and this will be added to my profile you
will also
find here some important links sometimes
like
this introduction to genomics is a
course that we will go through today
and you will see the schedule of our
sessions right here on the calendar so
you can see
all of the upcoming sessions here or
here
if you want to print it out or just
download to your computer you just
click on this button right here
several courses are included with this
uh program
including some uh projects like this one
uh or like this one and some basic
coursework like genomics
introduction to bioinformatics and
others and all of this point system
essentially takes you to the certificate
and the certificate
is based on completing the sessions
and earning a certain number of points
so once you achieve
those metrics you're going to get an
automated certificate which is going to
be displayed right here
and i will show you in a second you can
also download it
and you can also display it on your
profile
so as i mentioned we have a slack
channel
uh and if you click right here and ask
question it will take you to that slack
channel
so here on slack we have participants
from
the different programs and you'll be
able to
interact with us so if you have any
issues any questions
uh you can post your questions right
here you will see here also posted
the recorded sessions that we go through
and if you want to ask the public
question what you need to do
is just type in question and this is
going to be
displayed on the program page
so right here
you can go through and you see it will
be posted
right here so that's how this works this
is a page that's supposed to kind of
integrate all of the different aspects
of what we're going to be doing
and guide you through these steps so
that you know where we are
where we're going and how to get there